I find that that
um in doing research on you and your
even your Beginnings it seems to be a a
path that you were meant to go on like
as a a little kid growing up in
Massachusetts yeah yeah uh you uh your
parents were carnies
well it was kind of like
um yes but not like freak Show carnies
no like kind of like uh food concessions
and things like my mom really grew up in
that world and then when she married my
dad she dragged him into it and then we
were born we got dragged into it but as
a kid we're always at a carnival yeah
like it was mostly in the Summers
because we're in school so summertime we
had to work the carnivals but they
weren't like they were kind of low rent
and always in bad neighborhoods
right so we sort of hated it but we sort
of liked it as kids I don't know well
you don't know any different right so
you're working at a carnival the the
you're you're Segway out of a carnival I
read was
um
like a kind of a riot
broke out there was gunshots fires they
were burning down tents you're a little
kid at a carnival yeah this was I think
1977 because I remember or I don't know
it was around that time
and um yeah it was just like the typical
Carnival you know all the gambling tents
are rigged so I guess you would is that
true well at this show it was I don't
know I can't speak for every Carnival
but
um there's this really good movie called
Carney right with Gary Busey and Jody
Foster and that is exactly how it is
that movie and it's really kind of
sleazy that's the world anyway so yeah
these these guys were getting cheated on
the tents I think they finally figured
it out and they were drunk they came
back then they lit the tent on fire but
the whole Midway just went we just
everything went up on fire because
nothing was fireproofed obviously it was
just one after another and then you
started hearing popping sounds and all
the guys that worked like the Tilt the
world and all these things started
pulling out guns which none of this I
knew was happening as a kid until it
happened and that was when my parents
were like
we're done it got all crazy and violent
now that's good yeah no well they knew
where to draw the line yeah at the fire
and the shooting and then the gunshots
and the yeah the last thing I remember
was uh I can't remember this guy's name
but he was like
he was yelling to me and my brother
because my brother's there too was even
younger and he was like hey come over
here come over here and just as he was
telling us to get out of the way of the
chaos somebody hit him in the head with
a hammer and I was like just you saw
that yeah it was he was yelling to us
and somebody yeah and what did you see I
saw kind of his head kind of bust open
and just blood gushed out everywhere and
him fall down and and that's when you
said I don't know what a great scene for
a fish carnival life is amazing let's go
to Disney but just to actually not a lot
of kids have actually seen somebody's
head bust open and because a lot of your
in your music videos and a lot of your
movies there's a lot of blood and guts I
guess so I was always I was remember how
they'd say if you watch too many violent
movies and things you become
desensitized
you do and that was me so I was very
desensitized to that type of stuff and I
don't know the funniest thing about that
whole Carnival incident I remember going
back to school I don't know maybe it was
like third grade or something and you
had to write what happened that summer
and I wrote that yeah like most kids
were like oh we went canoeing yes and
well your name's not Rob was it Rob it's
not right yeah first name's Rob yes oh
okay
I don't know I know that Rob Zombie is
not your real name no but Rob is my name
that is not Bob no that was my dad and I
was get really pissed as a little kid
when someone called me Bob
not to be confused with Bob zombie your
dad right yes so that's his name yes so
were you desensitized when that happened
were you already watching a lot of
horror and probably yeah it just it
didn't give me nightmares it didn't
bother me I mean I knew it was messed up
but I don't know there was just maybe it
was like it just seemed like it was on
TV to me I don't know
I remember just watching being always
watching movies I was too young to be
watching so maybe that was why
[Music]